[Music]
in this morning Saturday sashen Lucius
for over a decade the band led by two of
the more striking vocalists around have
collaborated with artists like Roger
Waters Mavis Staples and John Legend
they're also known for their unique
style as you'll see this month the band
just released their third record they'll
perform for you in a bit but first I
spoke with them at New York's Town Hall
just before their headlining show the
front women of the band Lucius Holley
Lessig of Cleveland and just wolf from
Los Angeles met in school at Berklee
College of Music in Boston what did you
hear the first time you sang together it
was an automatic musical vocal kinship
we have very different voices separately
of one another but together it formed
pretty instantly this third entity well
how can we both be lead singers and do
this together I think it was an accident
at first because we were both gonna sing
the melody and we just both started
singing it and in the headphones
because we were in the studio and in the
cans it sounded like a double track
vocal it can be pretty thrilling when
you hear something unique come out of
two separate voices yeah it's hard to
sing alone now
[Music]
they moved to New York to form a band
and began to dress alike and then look
alike how did the theatrical part of
this we had a friend our friend James
who was like I mean you sound like one
why don't you dress like one did you
settle on a look pretty quickly or did
it just sort of take its own route it's
still taking its own route is there a
mental transformation when you when you
do this yeah definitely I mean it
definitely helps you become a different
person it's like a character I think
that was part of it for us from the
beginning you know to feel like we can
also be transported along with the
audience
[Music]
Lucius released their debut album
wildwoman in 2013 their follow-up good
grief
lifted them into the top 100 of the
Billboard albums chart their new album
nudes includes a performance with Roger
Waters who they met at the Newport Folk
Festival in 2015 J sweet who runs from
Newport called us up and said Roger was
doing a surprise set and he's looking
for some singers and you're the ones can
you do it yes we can
that show was incredibly special just a
unforgettable moment mm-hmm and
afterwards he wrote us and said we're
brothers and sisters now let's do this
again and oh by the way I'm doing a
concert in the desert with Paul
McCartney Neil Young The Rolling Stones
Bob Dylan who do want to do it okay
yeah they performed at the desert trip
Festival in California in 2016 and then
joined waters on his world tour was it
160 dates like that but it introduced
lucious to a new audience
Jes wolf and Holly Lessig have been
singing together now for 13 years
it's like any relationship or thing that
you find in your life that feels
I don't know dreamlike or perfect or
whatever the word is
it felt dreamlike yeah it felt like
there was never a moment where we said
we shouldn't be doing this